Just like the long awaited jet packs
and hoverboards of tomorrow--
smart contact lenses have been a long time coming.
However, a new way of putting electronics
into a contact lens is one step closer to making
contacts that can collect information and display it.
Researchers have created a contact lens
that monitors glucose levels in tears
and signals via an LED light.
This could help diabetics do away
with painful daily blood tests.
In the past, contact lenses integrated with electronics
were stiff and potentially harmful
to the sensitive human eye.
Here, the components are all flexible
and, for the most part, transparent.
The graphene glucose sensor, the antenna,
and the LED are all embedded in a silicon hybrid
substrate that sits on top of a breathable contact lens.
The lens can stretch up to 30 percent.
And is around 90 percent transparent.
The lens is powered wirelessly through an antenna
that encircles the pupil, preventing obstruction of sight.
When glucose levels in the wearer rise to
a predetermined amount,  the LED pixel turns off.
Though this is a good proof of concept, there is still
a ways to go these lenses haven’t been tested
in people and there isn’t a practical way to power them.
But with a few improvements,
we could be seeing a lot more with our eyes.